okay I think everybody knows my first
guest she's the representative from San
Francisco and the 52nd Speaker of the
House for the United States of America
Nancy Pelosi thank you very much for
doing this welcome to my game room and I
have many questions for you in these
difficult times the first one being
everyone seems to agree testing is the
way to get back to normal normality in
America and it's the most frustrating
thing is it seemed like it would even
help Trump but he seems to be dragging
his feet on this most important issue is
there any way Congress can pass their
own plan well what we passed today which
we just finished passing is the testing
we have twenty five billion dollars in
there for testing but we require that
there be a national strategic plan for
testing and that we have reporting back
as to how it is impacting all
communities communities of color and
diversity in our country so it insists
on that but it we we passed our first
bill this is our fourth bill all
bipartisan first bill was March 4th was
called testing testing testing here we
are more than a month and a half later
and we still have to pass another bill
it's very hard to understand why they
are dragging their feet or whatever the
brains or whatever not to realize that
if you want to open up the economy
test test test contact race incubate um
isolate nah you know it's it's so simple
you have to not only test at race and
shelter in place until it the coast is
clear
ok you mentioned that this is the fourth
bill you've passed I think the total now
is coming up on two point seven trillion
dollars hmm that's a lot of you know
money in a very short period of time
I know Congress controls the purse
strings I can't imagine there's much
left in the purse I just don't get it I
don't understand how I know we can bail
out certain sectors as we have done in
the past
I don't know how you can just keep
indefinitely writing checks we were 20
trillion in the hole to begin with and
and all world governments who are you
know already in debt are doing this how
can the whole world be writing this
funny money
well because it's a matter of life and
death nobody as big a fuss as we did
when they pass our nearly two trillion
dollar tax break for the wealthiest
people in our country eighty-three
percent of the benefits going to the top
one percent and a debt that that later
on our kids to pay for in the future I
said but this is more of an investment
and like the lives and the livelihood of
the American people and we have to think
big about that the more we invest in
science and health the quicker
our economy will recover from the
pandemic well it will recover and unless
people get wise to the fact that we're
just writing checks for money that
doesn't exist I mean what is what is the
point of bailing out banks who and
they're just gonna loan back the money
that doesn't exist to us again I it
seems like it's a house of cards that
that could in the end wind up hurting
more people than the disease well the
point is to keep people working its
paychecks retention and so the point of
these this legislation for the Paycheck
Protection a program is that the small
businesses would be able to have some
relief and if they kept their workers on
and they would have debt forgiveness and
that is a very important part of it we
were concerned when they asked for more
money right away we said wait a minute
we want to make sure we want to see the
data you know that we have seen
anecdotally not scientifically yet is
telling us that many low that we say
underbanked communities were not getting
any of this money whether it was women
and minority owned businesses Native
American veterans world communities etc
we're not getting these loans because
they they just didn't have banking
relationships that were putting them
either up in the line
up in the line so it is probably well it
is an investment and it is stimulant to
the economy when that probably when that
comes but is not anything in comparison
to the irresponsibility of a tax cut
almost two trillion dollars when you
count the interest on the debt that all
of these deficit hawks its fiscal
conservatives didn't even give one ounce
of thought to the fact is we expect
return on this money when we invest in
food stamps
that's stimulus when we invest in
unemployment insurance that stimulus
when we give a direct payment that
stimulus and hopefully when we keep
these people in their jobs and that was
the blow jobs small business but also
the assistance to the aerospace industry
the airline industry like that the point
is they keep the people in their jobs
and therefore they have paychecks and
therefore they can serve people can
survive it's a tough time because the
lives are throw their lives are
threatened as well as their loudly as
well as our democracy I might add that
we're gonna have money in there for
elections for direct well the the CDC
this week said it might come around
again in in the fall can we afford to do
the whole thing again can we afford to
spend this kind of money a second time
in one year I think that it should be
clear that this is not doing the job
that is set out to do completely that we
may have to consider some other options
others have proposed a sovereign fund
which go to the these unemployed people
won't work guaranteed income other
things that may not even be as costly as
continuing down this path but there is a
reverence for small business in our
country as the entrepreneurial spirit
the optimism of job creation wealth
creation and the rest and it's a good
place to how people stay in business but
even if they stand business because
we're giving this loan which if they
keep people employed they get
they don't have to pay back that the
rent is paid the utilities are paid
employees are there at the end of the
time they still have to have customers
and that's really why we need everybody
that's all we need another bill that
will be costly and we call it our hero's
bill and that's for state and local but
it's not what not state and local you're
across your aqua see it's health care
workers police and fire emergency
services people our teachers our transit
workers all of the people that are paid
for by the local state and local a
public sector they need jobs too and
they right now are the ones on the front
line risking their lives to save other
people's lives and and on top of that
they may lose their jobs because of the
the loss of revenue for the state so
that will be our next villain it will be
hundreds of billions of dollars as well
to states and localities counties
municipalities city some bigger than
small towns but nonetheless all having
the responsibility of meeting the needs
health care needs if corner virus they
also recognize the revenue loss that
they have and that has to be recognized
as a cost of the Kulin a virus so if
there's more there's more Chicana that
it's not necessarily the same day in a
small business but it's jobs jobs jobs
so the way we see it is all about
keeping people employed keeping people
employed but that's why we're having
them we passed today I was very pleased
so a committee on the current virus to
make sure that the money spent is money
that is spent we're helping people keep
their jobs not not the fishing
shareholders or dividends bonuses
corporate CEO pay or anything like that
that angers the American people and it's
not right secondly people want the
paychecks whether it's unemployment
insurance whether it's direct payment
whether it's PPP the like page this
small business initiative and the third
thing is they first and foremost I
thought should have said they want these
first response
to be protected the health care
providers that first responders to be
protected for what they are doing there
are heroes but we I think are unworthy
to praise them and thank them unless
we're going to what them okay well I
thank you for doing this
I hope Trump doesn't steal all that
money I do worry about that committee to
make sure that the money is spent to the
best and and by the way the good news is
the American people are paying attention
they are watching and we want and what
we are doing to change make change
that's so not all this hundreds of
billions dollars is not is not a way to
harden the disparity and access to
credit that is they're about to melt
that down and that's what the bill that
we're passing today Oh strives to do
thank you I appreciate it everything you
do madam Speaker and I hope I see you in
person very soon I hear your concern
about the national debt a bill that we
don't want our children to pay so we
have to grow the economy to make it a
national debt is one thing I'm worried
about you know the whole thing
collapsing and we going into a
depression but let's end on a happy note
and hope that doesn't happen make sure
it doesn't and that way that's why we
had to win the election in November
okay yes I agree with that all right
thank you take care of yourself you too
thank you
you